est ce que ça vous dirait d'avoir un pc
avec un écran isp lycée airbus qui vient
de sortir son nouveau un bouc 17 fold
oled fermé vous avez un écran de 12
points 5 pouces pour déposer votre
clavier dessus et lorsque vous l'ouvrez
en grand et que vous ouvrez le cheval et
vous avez un écran de 17,3 pouces ou
poser clavier devant vous travaillez
lors il ya six modes différents tu peux
utiliser comme une tablette comme une
liseuse bref comme on veut schultz a
super bien de voir ce qu'on peut venir
faire avec des écrans qui se plie et
pourquoi pas la voir sur pc moi ce que
vous en pensez ça pourrait vous tentez
oui non ou alors pas du tout